hello everybody hope they are good today
is Friday last trading day of the week
so there are a few things that I want to
talk about we're want to talk about the
weekly time frame also about some
altcoins uh potential trades with
altcoins over the weekend and obviously
the the trading setup that I'm waiting
for Bitcoin to develop okay uh so far I
can tell you that I'm not in a position
because my trigger hasn't been activated
yet and we're going to go through every
single detail in this video I've already
checked the liquidation heat map and
other book there are not changes since
yesterday so basically we still have
some liquidations of 53,1 15 that's
around this area here right above these
previous highs and also all the way to
50,000 there are some liquidations to
around this level which matches
perfectly with this liquidity pool and
also this psychological level of 50,000
so some liquidations to the upside and
to the downside not much Clear
information because if for example there
was no liquidation to the upside a tell
you yes we're for sure going to go low
there is no reason to go higher but
having those liquidations also up there
be careful okay that's why we are
playing very careful here we are not uh
being impatient Traders because they get
wrecked we've seen it this week we are
sticking to high probability trades and
that's why if we miss a move no problem
we're going to catch another one but we
are not going to lose money okay Capital
preservation guys first of all I want to
talk about the weekly time frame because
this is a this is something that I
talked about last Friday and I think
it's it's it's a good idea to to post a
followup about this well we were talking
about two resistant levels in the weekly
time frame there is one clearly at
60,000 that one there you can see here
guys resistance resistance resistance
resistance drop support support support
push to the new highs so that's a very
clear resistance 60,000 Al psychological
level you can see that's where the the
manipulation displays Market maker
building shorts here work to the upside
price not in further and here the same
Works to the downside price not progress
in fera Mark Mak Longs push higher and
this is something that I want I'm going
to mention soon later in this video
about 50,000 okay because that's going
to be also psychological level but
anyway let's not jump into that yet the
other resistance level that is very uh
close to us is uh
52,000 you can see here
it's more something like 50
1,00 and last week we were saying that
it would be very important to see
Bitcoin closing Above This level at
least for two weeks last week we managed
to do it just by $150 but that's enough
you know look at the candle is closed
above the level that line but this
weekly Candlestick is not doing the same
guys look at that red candle we're so
far closing below it I mean it's only
$1,000 maybe we see a pump today today
or over the weekend and we close above
the level and then we can favor upside
and in that case we would favor upside
to 60k so we would take a swing long
from 52,000 all the way to 60,000
because if you notice here in the chart
there is no any clear resistance okay so
it seems quite easy that path between
52,000 to 60,000 but to me it's very
important to see this candle closing
about 52,000 because otherwise this
looks like a rejection to me look at
that that looks like a rejection to me
and if that's the case we're going to
have to be very careful next week all
right now we've talked about the weekly
time frame so far it's not looking good
we need 52,000 recovery in the next two
days which seems quite
unlikely let's see what happens today
now for our time frame this is where all
the magic is is taking place the 4H hour
50a guys we've been talking about this
level for a few days
look at that okay is we're playing
around it's more like a choppy price
action because we keep testing a support
then we lose it by the next candle we
recover it and that's why I'm been very
patient here okay and all I'm looking is
for two candlesticks to test it a
resistance if that is not the case then
I'm not going short because this example
here that is not the case because some
of you are asking me today are you in
sure are you in short pay attention to
this okay this candle
here this candle here closes below the
4our 50 May and now we need two
Candlestick to test our resistance we
have one but the second one is not the
case it's a GRE Candlestick closing back
above it so no trigger for me it's as
simple as that if this Candlestick would
have closed $100 lower and that would be
below the 50 ma8 testing our resistance
then yes I would been going short right
now but I is not not the case does that
mean that we can't drop already today to
50,000 no it can still happen it just
means that is not as high of a probility
trade and that's why I'm not taking it
myself okay I prefer to be patient here
again so if that is the case that we
drop right now today or tomorrow to
50,000 I'm going to be pay attention to
to that level and the behavior of bitco
around that level okay let's mark in the
chart that's around that level we're
going to do
exactly there you go 50,000 look at that
manipulation guys that's what I mean um
and in my opinion there are three
reasons why we could go to 50,000 first
of all this liquidity pull here that
liquidity pool that is very interesting
probably my indicator is marking it yep
there it is look it's also marking here
a couple of weeks this one go failed
it's marking this new week here and that
one there all right right so uh the most
interesting is that liquidity pool that
is huge that's the first reason why
price could go to 50,000 to to retrace
this liquidity pool and with that I'm
going to include the liquidation hit map
in high Capital that it's showing a lot
of liquidations at the same level so all
of that Liquidations in this candle be
careful with that second reason open
interest capap we talked about this I
think uh it was in yesterday's video it
was to be ago in case you want to check
it out but open interest refers to the
total open positions this includes short
and long positions both of them it
doesn't include buy or sell limit orders
only already opened positions all right
and the market is always trying to find
a balance and trying to to take as much
as many orders as possible because yes
when there are when a trade opens an
order there are there is going to be
money generating through fees and also
in crypto is two fees where when you
open the trade and when you close the
trade so for the market Mak it is very
important to trigger all those orders
and to have the retail Trader putting
money in the chart simple as that that's
how they make money okay so if there is
an open interest gap between
,700 and
,200 that's basically between these two
levels here okay that orange books
that's an open interest Gap and that is
telling you that there are not many o
Open trades in this Zone because price
shifted away from that zone very quickly
in the last 90 days and if you notice
you mean we are spiking to that level
but we are not dropping lower we are not
consolidating in thean box we're not
doing this so trades canot open any
positions that means that there is a gap
here there is an imbalance in the order
book and there could be a rason or an
intention for the for price to drop to
this level consolidate fill the open
interest Gap more money into into
Bitcoin because of course there are some
traders that are saying I'm not going
long or I'm not going short until we for
example hang on let me let me redo this
there are some traders that are thinking
like this okay check that out that's a
that's a support so there are some
traders that are thinking I'm going to
go long here because I'm expecting a
sweep of the highs that's why there is
an open interest Gap there okay because
there are some Traders waiting to go
long in the area and also short because
there are some Traders thinking okay I'm
when to go short once we break below
this level okay that's my moment to go
short so that's why there is an open
interest Gap in the area so to retrace
that open interest Gap that is the the
second reason why price could go to
50,000 because it goes to
,200 and of course the third reason is
50,000 simply 50,000 is a psychological
level where a lot of retail Traders are
going to engage with price are going to
open trades because they are saying okay
prices are 51,000 and I see a lot of
people talking about 60,000 70,000 100K
new high so 50,000 to some people might
sound even cheap right now and that
might be one they want to buy that's why
if we drop to
50,000 in my opinion that's a third
reason psychological level where the
market maker knows that the retail
Trader is Will engage with price okay
and then of course once we go and if we
go to 50,000 we're going to be paying
attention to the reaction okay weeks to
the downside but price not progressing
any further below 50,000 it means the
same as it did here okay Market maker is
building the reversal that will be back
up so that's what I want to say
regarding Bitcoin now there is something
quite interesting now if you know this
Bitcoin what is bitcoin doing well
Bitcoin since Friday 16th one week ago
is pretty much consolidating right this
range is not going anywhere so far at at
least for now and it's ranging
consolidating it dropped from Fridays
through let me check while
Friday depends how you want to say it
but I mean to be this it's not even a
drop it's just consolidating okay but if
you go to the Bitcoin
dominance check it that out this was
Friday yes we were saying that it was
going to go
down but please check what happened
since Friday the bit dominance is
dropping very fast very fast look at
that drop it's huge
so in
principle altcoin shouldn't be very
affected right because if Bitcoin is is
stable let's say although it seems that
there are some signs to for the downside
more than to the upside that's my
opinion and the Bitcoin dominance is
going down then Alon should be fine but
they are not look at that
pay attention to chain link dropping pay
attention to
Solana
dropping
ax
dropping what is going on it doesn't
make that much sense okay if you
understand the cycle between Bitcoin and
the Bitcoin
dominance it doesn't make much sense
that alons are bleeding this hard okay
that's what I think I'm going to fade
this move and I'm going to be looking
for Longs over the weekend we're going
to going to the Daily time frame well
actually not we're going to St the four
time frame
but um no I want the 50 ma to se in the
daily time
frame look at aox guys aox is so far
holding the daily 50a I also see some
weeks to the downside but price is not
really dropping I'm breaking this Zone
that is telling me that you know there
might be a reversal in play for the
weekend and a reversal in play might be
all the way to
$39 okay that's around 8% move hang on
let me
check yes 8% move okay that's what I'm
paying attention to let's see how we
close uh today's
chart let's see how the what happens
today because obviously if we drop today
to 50,000 then ax is going to go lower
okay
it's going to follow Bitcoin that's
clear but before I jump into any Longs
on altcoins I'm going to wait to see
what happens today I I'm going to wait
until midnight of tonight UTC time and
then um I'm going to see what has
happened if Bitcoin has held in this
range where it is right now then I'm
going to open some Longs in altcoins but
obviously if we if we drop today to
50,000 we're going to have cheaper
prices okay and that's when we're going
to pay attention to the next level so
then aax wouldn't be interesting to me
if that's the case that Bitcoin drops to
50,000 because aax would follow it would
lose this this level here that that's to
me the level of Interest so I would
ignore aex I would go to Solana and then
the same I would be checking with Solana
okay right now Tana it seems the same WS
to the downside price not breaking below
it seems like they are make they are
building Longs but if Bitcoin drops
today to 50,000 then Solana is going to
follow and I'm going to pay attention to
the Daily f ma if we can hold up the
daily 50ma when the New York station
closes that's what I'm going to open
Longs over the weekend favoring a
reversal because yes I don't believe
what it's going on I'm going to fade
this move of the Bitcoin dominance and
Al because it's not making any sense to
me that's what I see the chart okay it's
not making any sense why is altcoins
bleeding so hard when the Bitcoin
dominance is dropping a lot and Bitcoin
is ranging I'm faing that move okay um
so that's what I'm going to I'm going to
wait same with chain
link okay if Bitcoin drops today to
50,000 chain link is going to get to the
50 AMA in the daily time frame that's
right now
$17.32 and that and if we call this
level after the New York SE finishes and
closes that's Rel to wait for a reversal
okay a very aggressive reversal over the
weekend that's what I'm paying attention
to um I'm going to update you uh tonight
through the through the telam channel
that is free um I like to post updates
about altcoins there so we're going to
be paying attention to
bitcoin again I'm not in any trade on
bitcoin I do think that it's more likely
that it drops to 50,000 then that it
goes to
53,000 when can this happen can it
happen today or will it happen from
Monday that's the question okay I'm not
in a position I'm not in a short right
now because to me it's not a high prity
trade it's not very clear to me to me
okay so I'm going to wait see how
Bitcoin closes today and then play with
altcoins over the weekend so that's
basically everything that I want to say
guys and one more thing before I finish
the video stay tuned uh to to X and to
the telegram Channel because today I'm
going to announce at what time tomorrow
I'm going to open new slots for the
course in the website okay so uh I stay
tuned because tomorrow in the website
we're going to open your slots for the
course course that will start in 10 days
so uh it's probably going to be a lot of
interest and if you've been waiting for
the chance uh try to H be tomorrow at
that time to not miss out okay so that's
pretty much everything guys thank you so
much for watching all the videos this
week because I know that some of you
watch the videos Monday to Friday um I
appreciate it I feel like I have a
responsibility to guide you well of
course no Financial advice but I'm
trying my best so thank you so much guys
for watching and I'll see you soon